gerson tiene una sensación de libertad
desde La retirada de las tropas rusas
los 8 meses de ocupación dejaron a una
ciudad desangrada pero los habitantes
van encontrando poco a poco su
orientación y sus costumbres
como aquí en la plaza principal donde se
ha instalado un puesto de teléfonos
móviles para los residentes
las tarjetas sí eran rusas he intentado
todo este tiempo no usarlas estas
tarjetas son ucranianas Esta es la señal
de nuestra Victoria estamos liberados
Gloria Ucrania y a sus Héroes
los militares son vistos como Héroes a
pocos metros este soldado está
repartiendo autógrafos y haciéndose
fotos con los civiles pero por ahora no
se debería cantar Victoria incluso
siendo la retoma de gerson un tema de
Gran importancia para las fuerzas
defensoras
nuestra única opción es hacerlos
retroceder aún más por seguirlos hasta
el final
con la liberación de cartón y sus
alrededores ya se están denunciando
numerosos casos de tortura Durante los
meses de ocupación los prisioneros
fueron supuestamente atados golpeados o
electrocutados por los rusos
identificaron una docena de centros de
detención en los distritos de gerson los
ciudadanos fueron detenidos ilegalmente
allí los civiles fueron tomados como
Rehenes por los rusos la tortura se
llevó a cabo en cuatro lugares que
actualmente están siendo examinados por
los investigadores
en este sentido se han abierto más de
430 expedientes en esta región los
ucranianos afirman tener elementos que
podrían ser calificados como crímenes de
guerra